hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man far
from home has been out long enough for
us to ponder again and again overly
complex plot of the villain Mysterio a
magician of sorry illusionist whose very
appearance as a result of crazy vivid
holographic projections without even a
hint of buffering or lag see folks
secret is every human living in the MCU
lacks the skepticism lobe in their brain
so they just interpret all the goofy
looking things like wakandan rhinos or
extremists super soldiers is totally
plausible lifelike images they're all
suckers susceptible to Mysterio style
fakery but how deep does this fakery go
couldn't Mysterio have gone so far as to
fake his death
despite spider-man's apparent victory
did Peter Parker actually play right
into a deeper plan an elaborate
pre-scripted narrative all orchestrated
by Quentin Beck the whole time in the
even wider matrix deep illusion am i
further eroding a generation of minds
into forming very ignorant political
beliefs probably okay let's break down
Mysterio's actual plan and spiderman far
from home halfway through the film
Quentin Beck celebrates with his team in
a Prague bar over tricking Peter Parker
in the handing over eateth Tony Stark's
magic specs which can access Starks
whole database and control his vast
network of drones but if Beck and his
team only now got those drones what were
they using to project the phony
elementals before they got control of
Edith here's the deal the Mysterio team
previously possessed some of this tech
and they needed Edith to expand their
limited operation to a global scale and
trick the whole world into believing
Mysterio was a true Avenger Quentin Beck
was the original inventor of barf the
lifelike holographic tech that projects
super vivid imagery that was on Civil
War he was furious that start gave it a
pukey name and used it for what he
called self therapy but after getting
fired from Stark Industries Beck found a
new use for part in his victory speech
Beck shouts out William Ginter Riva the
former Stark Industries engineer whom
Obadiah Stane screamed box of scraps at
Riva engineered weaponized drones so
Beck combined his barf image projections
with Rivas drones so that they could
float around and sink and project
Holograms of Elemental monsters that
using weapons on the drones hidden
behind the Holograms actually smashed up
buildings and infrastructure in some
cases these drone
fire actual projectiles but I think most
of the destruction could have been
caused by sonic impact blasts like the
ones that they later use on Peter on
Tower Bridge to cause massive waves in
Venice or crumble masonry really this is
the same way visual effects work in
Hollywood films combining practical
explosions and demolitions onset with
projected CGI imagery in post-production
the sand elemental in Mexico the water
elemental in Venice in the fire
elemental and Prague were all created
this way they were all elaborately
pre-rendered by team Mysterio with the
attention to detail of a Hollywood
visual effects crew now in Prague one of
rivas drones was damaged and MJ
recovered a piece of a projector which
is how Peter later uncovered Beck's
whole plot but getting Edith changed the
game for Team Mysterio by expanding this
operation to what bet called an Avengers
level threat Edith grew their drone
fleet from a few hundred of rivas own
collection to a lot more from Starks
Legion up in a satellite this allowed
them to now create a calamity that
encompasses an entire major city like
the battles in New York and sokovia that
only Avengers could fix their plan was
to make Mysterio the world's new Avenger
which would give them unchecked power
over world governments and beloved
celebrity status in society in a sense
the kind of influence Tony Stark had now
when you've rewatched these earlier
scenes in far from her home it is crazy
to see the lengths that Quentin Beck
went to maintain the charade first when
Peter first arrives in Venice before the
water monster attack if you look closely
that can actually be seen hiding in
plain sight and tirsty street clothes
looking over his shoulder at Peter
this means that Beck knew that Peter
would be coming to Venice and his team
chose Venice as the location of their
next attack so that they could get Peter
involved win him over with Beck's charms
and eventually trick Peter into handing
over Edith later before the Prague
battle Mysterio floats up to Peter on
the rooftop for a quick chat that
floating Mysterio was a drone projected
image wouldn't Beck can't fly
he doesn't have rocket thrusters folks
in the scene Peter looks down and then
Mysterio appears at his side meaning
that the real Beck must have been hiding
on that rooftop and then I guess snuck
up beside Peter right as that Mysterio
hologram mapped onto him in his mocap
suit now I guess it's also possible that
the drones were projecting an empty
rooftop to mask out back until the
precise
that he needed to be visible to Peter
either way this must have required quite
a bit of rehearsal just imagine pecks
snapping at his team but what Peter sits
two feet to left
we need to render a 35 degree angle view
on this rooftop a/c unit for me to hide
behind otherwise you will see me in my
silly triangle unitard too early we're
creating illusions here people come on
and this brings us to Mysterio's death
in the final battle he appears to die
from a ricochet drone bullet to the gut
but after Peter smashes I've drawn after
thrown that Beck gasping for life on the
ground was a projection the real Stanley
Beck nearly got off a sucker shot now we
know that is the real Beck because Peter
grabs his arm and he snatches the Edith
glasses off his face flesh contact means
a real connection quoted directly for my
tinder profile but here's the
interesting moment Beck crumbles to the
ground as if that ricocheted bullet
actually did strike him and it gasps his
final words people need something to
believe in these days they'll believe
anything that Peter looks at back
through the glasses and asks Edith is
this real and Edith responds all
illusions are down but it's interesting
how Peter does not ask is Beck dead come
on Peter you're talking to a freaking
robot specificity is key like when I ask
Alexa Tobias star is born' I end up
buying like three wrong stars borns
before I get the Gaga 1 and then I
realized I was just trying to buy The
Bourne Supremacy so by all illusions are
down it is totally possible that Edith
is merely reporting that no Holograms
are being projected at this moment but
neither Edith nor Peter are checking for
a pulse here or sniffing that mocap suit
to see if Beck shot himself which folks
tape to ruin dramatic movie deaths for
you but it is what happens when you
croak
if Nick Fury can fake a flatline in
front of the world's sharpest super
soldier and deadly a spy a brilliant
illusionist and thespian can sell it to
fool a gullible dope who handed off the
MCU nuclear codes to a guy in a cape you
just met two days earlier also
immediately after this there is a shot
of Reva back at the computer terminal
whose smartphone screen shows a file
being downloaded now this we assume
later from the post-credits scene is the
doctored video of Quentin Beck framing
spider-man as the one responsible for
the attacks an Audi and MS Peter Parker
but also on that screen you can see the
words active drones 500 now this was
after Peter shut down all the drones
right but Peter only reacquired edith
not rivas personal drones that they were
using before they got Edith so Peter
could still be looking at 18 mysterio
controlled projection here and Edith
would have no idea and on top of that
when Peter handed off Edith de Becque
and bar earlier remember Edith required
a confirmation step before that
transference could be completed at no
point did Beth give any verbal
confirmation to transfer Edith back to
Peter no way he wouldn't do that so
consider that when Beck realized he was
defeated on Tower Bridge he resorted to
a contingency plan one in which he
surrendered Edith back to Peter
delivered his most oscar-worthy death
rattle and faked his death so that his
team could release a pre-recorded video
that turns this Mysterio hero figure
into a public martyr in spider-man into
a public enemy just as the greatest
trick the devil ever pulled is to
convince the world he doesn't exist the
only thing the world loves more than a
savior is a fallen and resurrected
Savior worked for gap and for Jesus in
the name eightieth is supposedly an
acronym from Tony Stark meaning even
dead I'm the hero folks
Mysterio's secret agenda was right under
our noses the whole time that Mysterio
always planned for a contingency in
which Peter Parker saw through the top
layers of his illusions but not all the
way to the bottom layer in which
Mysterio could live on as the hero by
appearing dead do you think Mysterio
could still be alive
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at EI vas and subscribe to new rock
stars for breakdown some theories about
everything Marvel thank you for joining
me in sadly it's possible to [ __ ] your
pants and not have died even
you wish you were dead
[Music]